[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to the tomes
of terror show my little book review
series that i do on here so let's talk
about this week's book
now because there are uh
i regret to say
way more worthwhile horror books out
there than i will ever have time enough
in my life to read which makes me very
sad
when i'm looking for something new to
read and review for the series i tend to
rely a lot on recommendations like from
other horror channels that i watch or
you know just every now and then i'll go
through and do like a blog post or
something like that or sometimes you
guys um you know recommend stuff that
sounds really good and stuff like that
so what ended up happening this week was
that i had one book that i had bought
like the print uh version of that
somebody recommended or that i saw
recommended somewhere
and
while i was kind of into it it was just
it wasn't really that long but i just
couldn't really get into it and it
seemed like kind of like a slog like to
have to finish it like before i will
finish it because it is good but it's
just kind of more like experimental and
i just guess i wasn't really in the mood
for that this week so basically i was
like okay well i have to read something
to get a review up in a timely fashion
so i said i know what i'll do i'll just
look for
a novella or you know something like
that that's shorter that i can you know
that's more compelling that i can read
through really quickly and stuff like
that so basically i go on google and i
do a search for best horror novellas
and i hit upon this list by i think it
was the lineup and it was called seven
terrifying horror novellas and the blog
post had been published back in december
i think of 2021 so it was fairly recent
now there were a couple of familiar
titles on there uh that i had been
wanting to read however none of them
were available for my kindle unlimited
plan except for the last one so i said
okay well this one's free so i'm gonna
give this one a whirl and it's on this
list of seven along with some other
books that i'd heard were really good so
i was like okay so maybe it'll be really
good so the last one that was listed was
a 2020 novella although it's just barely
a novella i feel like it's a little bit
longer than a standard novella i think
it's about 190 pages something like that
um but i hadn't heard of it previously
and it's actually called the rotting
within by matt kurtz
now matt kurtz i looked up his bio and
it seems that he started out as a
filmmaker screenwriter filmmaker uh
primarily
though it seems like he's more pivoted
into writing horror books a couple years
back
he published his first novel which was
called kinfolk back in 2018 and he's
also published three volumes of short
stories
and i have to say if all of those are as
good as the rotting within was then i'm
gonna have to check out more of his [ __ ]
like sooner rather than later this one
was
super fun i mean it was like a hell of a
ride it's fast paced it's action-packed
it's very uh the descriptions of it are
very immersive it really like puts you
in the world it's gory uh it's
disgusting it's very cinematic and it's
actually like
scary like it actually has scary parts
in it and has a real gut punch of an
ending
everything
that we know and like about the horror
genre it's just all in this one tight
little package which like i said clocked
into less than 200 pages this is how you
do it if you want to write just a really
good entertaining
horror story that just doesn't let up i
mean this is definitely one of the best
ones that i've read recently uh also
somebody needs to make a movie of this
like yesterday because i would totally
watch it so the story starts out with
two very short prologues like the first
one is literally like a few paragraphs
and the second one is maybe like a page
like a couple pages
so the first of these prologues uh has
to do with a woman named shirley
and for reasons that we don't uh
immediately know
she abandons her child and her abusive
husband in the dead of night and then
goes off to meet a mysterious stranger
then we have the second prologue which
jumps ahead 15 years
shirley returns to her former home and
her former abusive husband
but now she's
different
the dirtbag husband ends up getting torn
to shreds in a very graphic and
disgusting scene by some kind of monster
and then we get on with the main part of
the story so the bulk of the story takes
place 26 years later like 26 years after
that
so we're following a young woman named
kenzie uh who seems like a good person
at heart but has tragically bad taste in
men
she has two kids uh nine-year-old lily
and five-year-old tim uh by two
different fathers and lately has been in
a
very disastrous relationship with yet
another abusive [ __ ] named paul now
she'd been putting up with his [ __ ] for
a while because she was poor i think she
just worked like as an administrative
assistant or something like that she
didn't really have enough money to live
out on her own with her two kids and
everything so she needed a roof over her
head so she was willing to like put up
with his [ __ ] just you know for a
place for her kids to grow up
but uh after she caught paul leering at
her daughter one morning uh and you know
what that means she decided she had to
get the [ __ ] out of dodge asap before
something really really horrible
happened
so since she was desperate didn't have
any money saved up or anything like that
she ended up stealing several hundred
dollars from paul's hidden stash packed
her kids [ __ ] into her suv or whatever
and hightailed it out of the state now
she didn't really have any close family
or friends like her friends had mostly
she had like burned bridges with them or
because of her series of abusive
boyfriends you know he had like cut off
contact so he had kind of like isolated
her from other people so she don't
really have any close friends and she
doesn't also have any close family her
mother victoria had died of cancer quite
young like many years before
so kenzie decides that her only recourse
in this situation is
she's gonna be forced to impose on her
only remaining family member her
grandmother shirley uh who again was
from the beginning of the book uh now
she's actually never met her
through her mom like before her mom died
uh she found out that shirley runs this
out of the way bed and breakfast in this
small town in texas
so she is able to sort of like call
around and find out where shirley is
like where the inn is that she runs
and when she talks to shirley on the
phone she finds out that shirley is
actually seems like a lovely person and
is more than welcoming yes please come
out here
so kenzie also hopes that not only will
she be reconnecting with family and have
a place to stay
but because it's sort of out in the
middle of nowhere and she doesn't think
that her boyfriend um knows where it is
uh she's like okay well we're just gonna
escape and he's not gonna know where
we're going and he won't be able to find
us out there so it's win-win so kenzie
and the kids uh get to the sunrise bed
and breakfast
and at first everything just seems
idyllic at first
as usual in these kind of stories
shirley i mean is exactly the kind of
grandmother you could ever hope for that
anyone could ever hope for
uh and she basically offers kenzie and
the kids she's like you can stay here as
long as you need to
and she even agrees like she puts kenzie
to work in the inn you know so she
doesn't feel like she's getting charity
or whatever and she's like look it's
only just me working here so i need help
anyway so you'd be doing me a favor you
know shirley says we don't really have
that many visitors anymore we're kind of
out in the middle of nowhere but we do
have people wandering in from time to
time and she likes to keep it ready for
them so they keep it like super clean
and everything is like ready for guests
it turns out though that the inn does
have two very long-term residence
and this is a pair of elderly ladies
who live in the only two rooms on the
third floor and have lived there quite
quietly a little bit like hermits for
more than 30 years they're like friends
of shirley's
now the slightly younger woman whose
name is myrna uh is a bit abrasive like
doesn't really have a lot of social
graces like kind of just like blurts out
what she thinks
uh but she otherwise seems decent enough
the other woman who is much older is
named lucille and she's apparently
bedridden so for a long time the story
you never see her
uh myrna takes take care of the old
woman uh explaining she's a you know
she's her nurse or whatever kenzie and
the kids like even though they are kind
of like put to work around the end like
you know putting away linens and things
like that um but they're like well just
try to stay away from the third floor
other than like taking food up to them
and stuff like that just don't disturb
them because they really like their
privacy and stuff like that so kind of
like keep to your quarters on the lower
floors unless it's absolutely
unavoidable so at this point kenzie is
starting to think hey maybe i'm finally
getting my life back together um you
know this inn it's like this gorgeous
old place uh shirley her grandmother is
very very sweet very supportive and
apparently her dirtbag ex-boyfriend paul
has no idea where she is and doesn't
really have much way of finding her
also shortly after she arrives uh this
handsome new guest named ben kind of
blows in
and kenzie befriends him it's though
it's nice to be able to like kind of
talk and sometimes they kind of flirt
and like drink wine out on the porch and
chat or whatever um but she kind of
keeps him at arm's length a little bit
keeps things platonic because
it seems that maybe he might be on the
run from the law
you know and lord knows she doesn't need
to be going down that road again given
her history but of course this is a
horror story so uh there are some weird
things going on in this place
um so said weird things include kind of
like weird noises behind the walls and
like thumping up in the attic stuff like
that
uh doors sometimes being open when they
could have uh when they should be closed
there's like weird shadows uh kind of
moving around the house unexplained cold
breaths on the back of your neck every
now and then [ __ ] like that and myrna
the younger of the two old ladies when
she finally appears seems helpful uh you
know especially like when one of the
kids gets sick and like i said she was a
nurse and she seemed super helpful and
everything but she's also very
blunt and she's very caustic
and she has these kind of like bizarre
mannerisms that you know that kenzie
can't really like figure out what it is
there's also kind of weird [ __ ] where
the house is sort of like surrounded by
these woods and there does seem to be
like something out in the woods and
there's like weird symbols like carved
into some of the trees [ __ ] like that
uh also the youngest kid tim who is five
he uh watches a scary movie one night
against the wishes of his mom
and he has what uh seems to be a
nightmare about a naked old lady
hovering over his sister's bed like
doing stuff to her so you know there's
that now only a few days after kenzie
moves into the b and b
shirley is unexpectedly called away to
stay with a sick friend
leaving kenzie in charge of the place
now
this is stressful enough obviously
especially for somebody as unsure of
herself as kenzie is i mean she's only
been here a couple of days and she's not
really sure she can run this by herself
without [ __ ] it up so that's
stressful enough but then all of this
other kind of stressful [ __ ] happens
turns out there's this line of really
really horrible thunderstorms and
flooding and stuff like that heading
their way which you know obviously will
end up like knocking out the power and
phones and [ __ ] like that
uh both of the kids have
fallen ill with some mysterious illness
uh and can't really eat or get out of
bed and are like vomiting and stuff
um turns out that kenzie's boyfriend
paul might have figured out uh where
they are after all and is possibly on
his way there like to exact some
retribution for her like taking off and
stealing his money
and oh by the way there might also
be some kind of supernatural creature of
some kind creeping around in the house
with them so as i mentioned i mean this
is just about as perfect a horror story
as you could possibly want it's
page turning it's riveting it's gross
and disgusting there's gore
it's tense it's creepy
and as the story goes on like the stakes
just keep getting higher and higher and
higher like she just keeps getting in
like worse and worse and worse like and
it's just kind of like this compounding
like thing of like [ __ ] this [ __ ] storm
of like stuff coming at her uh it's also
really really like beautifully written
and it sort of kind of plunges you into
the story with these really i mean it's
the the way that things are described
it's very succinct but um it's very
vivid so you can really kind of like see
it that's why i meant when i said it was
cinematic like you can really see the
whole thing like playing out in your
head which like i said you know matt
kurtz would start out as filmmakers so
that shouldn't be a surprise i guess
also love that the author went all in
with a really wrenching ending but
seriously as soon as i was getting
toward the end and i figured out what
was happening i legit like out loud said
oh no oh no i just went like that like
as soon as i figured out what it was so
i got like real i was like oh [ __ ] no oh
that's awful so yeah it was like that i
mean take all of those things weave all
of that together with and you also have
kind of like a sprinkling of sort of
quick references to you know horror
classics rosemary's baby there's a
little bit of burnt offerings in there
stuff like that i mean this was just
a really really damn good
slice of delicious horror goodness and
really more people need to read this
like i said if you have kindle unlimited
uh you can read on there for free like i
did but
i mean something this good probably uh
be better to like buy the print which i
probably will as well because i really
really liked this a lot and i would like
to
re-read it uh at some point in the
future so yeah if you just want
something that's just like a fun gory
scary like roller coaster ride like a
classic horror story with some some nods
and homages to like classic horror but
it's kind of like its own thing then i
would definitely definitely recommend
this i had a blast with it and i think
you will too um it seems to have pretty
overwhelmingly positive reviews on
goodreads if that tells you anything so
check it out or if you've read it let me
know what you think about it in the
comments and we'll have a discussion
about it and that will do it for this
tomes of terror i will see you guys on
the next one bye